-Our next guest is
a Tony Award-winning actress
you know from her work
on Broadway
and "Sunday in the Park
with George"
and "You Can't Take It
with You,"
and shows such as "Master
of Sex" and "B Positive."
She stars in the highly
anticipated revival of
"Sweeney Todd: The Demon Barber
of Fleet Street,"
which is now in previews
at the Lunt-Fontanne Theatre.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Annaleigh Ashford,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello.
-Hello.
-I'm so happy to have you back.
-I'm so happy to be back.
-We've talked in the past.
You were here talking about
"Sunday in the Park
with George,"
which is also Sondheim.
And now you're doing Sondheim
again,
but very sadly,
we lost Stephen in 2021.
And I'm wondering,
how often do you think
about him in the process
of doing rehearsals
and previews for the show?
-I mean, every moment.
Every time I get to a new song,
I sort of think of it
as its own little puzzle,
which is very apropos
because he loved puzzles.
And so I kind of just
go to a little spot up in heaven
and say, "Hey. Let's go do a
puzzle together. Here we go."
You know. Kind of helps me
get through the show, too.
-Now, for those who don't know
about "Sweeney Todd,"
this is about a -- sort of
a revenge-seeking story.
Will you try your best
to explain it
to those who are uninformed?
-Yeah, so,
it's about this guy who --
[Valley Girl accent]
He's from London.
It's about this guy.
[ Laughter ]
He's from Londontown,
and, um, he, like --
He, like, goes back to London
to, like, seek revenge,
and he kills lots of people
and puts them into pies!
-He puts them into pies.
-It's a very bloody show.
-[Normal voice] Yeah.
-It's sort of like --
It's both a renowned musical,
and it's a horror movie,
as well.
-Yes.
I love that Stephen Sondheim
used to say,
"Well, it's a horror musical.
It's the only one of its kind."
There's, like,
no other horror musical.
-There's no other
horror musical.
And does this bring
a different sort of audience?
Have you found the reaction
to it is different
than, say,
when you were doing "Sunday"?
-You know, there's a --
[ Laughs ]
There's a magic right
at the top of the show
that is this, like,
undeniable scream,
right when you hear the organ,
and it feels like,
"Are we, like --
Are we at, like, one of those
scary movies on opening night?
Like, where we're gonna
grab each other?"
It's kind of thrilling.
It's wild.
I'm like, "Do you people know
you're at a musical?
Get ready. here we go."
-It's very physical, as well.
It's very funny, very physical.
And the physical-comedy element,
I'm wondering, when you're
rehearsing things like that,
you do have to be
fairly precise with it.
Has anything gone wrong
in the previews?
-Things go wrong
all of the time.
-Okay.
You know.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You know comedy.
You're like, "I hope it goes
well, but it may not.
So let's just see what happens."
Yeah, the other night,
we actually --
I jump on this little counter
in the pie shop,
and I jumped,
and I didn't make it.
-You didn't make it up
to the top?
-No. And then I --
-Wait. What happens when
you jump on a counter and miss?
-You just fall. You just fall.
-Yeah.
Would you fall in a way
that the audience thinks
it's planned
or is it very clear?
-The audience went --
[ Gasps ]
[ Laughter ]
I mean, that's happened
to me on stage before.
Has it happened to you?
-I don't know
if I've taken a fall.
I don't -- I mean,
I think early in my career,
no director
would let me do any jumping.
I think the very fact
that they trust you with that
speaks more highly
of your stage craft.
-I mean, what I would say is,
"If you fall, just tell
the audience you're okay."
'Cause I feel like they spent
the next 30 seconds
being like, "Is she okay?"
So I ran off stage.
I did a lot of, you know,
jumping and dancing.
I did a backwards somersault.
It was very uncomfortable.
For everybody. Including myself.
I'm, fine though. I'm fine.
-Your son is six and a half.
-Yeah.
-Now, he saw his first Sondheim
musical. Is that correct?
-He did. We got to New York.
We had been in L.A.
for the last couple years,
and we got to new York,
and I was like,
"He needs to see
a Broadway show."
He's old enough now."
And he's not gonna see mine.
Because it's a horror musical.
-Right.
-So it's not because of you.
He would be fine
seeing you on stage.
You're just in one
that's inappropriate.
-I hope so. I hope he would be
okay seeing me on stage.
You never know. You never know.
Yeah, so, we took him
to "Into the Woods,"
which I thought was perfect.
'Cause it's Sondheim, and I just
wanted that to be his first one.
And he loved it.
-That's so exciting.
-Yeah, he knew
what was happening.
-Were you checking in with him
constantly?
-Yes, to the point
where he was like,
"I know what's happening, Mom.
Back off." You know?
-That's really adorable.
Because, as I was telling you
backstage, my son,
who's about the same age,
went with my wife,
and I think he was totally lost,
so...
Again, it's not a contest.
People, you know, develop
at different speeds.
-Did he like the giant?
-He liked the giant.
-They all love the giant.
-Yeah, they all love the giant.
-Yeah.
-That's what he came home --
He failed to answer any of
my follow-ups about the giant.
He's like, "There was a giant."
I'm like, "Tell me more."
He's like, "Dad, go see
your own Broadway shows."
[ Laughter ]
Again, bloody, gory.
How -- I would imagine
there's so many logistics
to a show like this with
the sort of special effects
that you're not used to
in a Broadway show.
-There's so much blood.
That's one kind of fun thing.
You know when there's, like,
glitter in your
child's class project
or an outfit you're wearing --
I don't know.
Whatever you're using glitter
for. And you find it forever?
-Yeah.
-You know, they would say like,
"Glitter is like herpes."
Well -- Isn't that a thing?
[ Laughter ]
-The glitter stores
don't say that.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Like, no one at the ad agency
was like, "We got it!"
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Do you know what else somebody
--
Our choreographer
said the other day,
"You know, glitter is --
Glitter are like pubes.
You find them everywhere."
You were like, "Do you?"
-Nothing's worse than when
you make a big bold statement
like that and immediately
realize -- You're like,
"I might have a different
experience with pubes."
[ Laughter ]
-I mean --
And also when you find glitter,
you're like, "I found glitter!"
When you find a pube, you're not
like, "I found a pube!"
-Yeah.
-Also, with glitter,
you know where it came from.
I mean -- You're like -- Yeah.
"Is this one mine?
I mean, is it...?"
-"It's green. It's not silver.
Where'd it come from? Aah!"
But, yeah, what I was
leading to is, you know,
I find a lot of blood in places
that I would least expect it.
And 'cause, you know,
stage blood
is like glitter and pubes.
You find it everywhere.
-You -- That old Broadway adage.
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
-This is -- First of all,
I mostly just want
to thank you for being here,
because I did not realize
you're in previews,
so you're doing basically --
Again --
It's just a Broadway show.
It's just before it opens.
You're doing the whole thing.
-Yeah.
-But, also,
when you're in previews,
you're rehearsing all day,
as well.
-I was literally
just at rehearsal
in a weird sweatsuit outfit
that I should have --
[Dramatically] And then look.
I'm going to the Met Gala now.
Gonna lay down on this couch.
[Normal voice] But, yeah, I'm
about to go put on my sweatsuit
and then go back to the theater,
we'll run some stuff.
Like, the orchestra
comes at 6:30 tonight
to work on some things.
But it's crazy.
It's a crazy thing.
-So then -- I think we all --
For the laymen like myself,
we think of,
"Oh, my God. Opening.
It must get so stressful then."
But it must be such a relief
when you open.
-Oh! I remember
another show that I --
I did a show called
"Kinky Boots."
And I remember the night
after opening being like,
"This is the best show
of my life!"
And everybody's like,
"What? What's going on?"
I was like, "We opened!
We did it. We already did it.
And now we get to do the show."
There's kind of this
magical release.
-Yeah, it must be just a really
nice day when all you have to do
is focus on doing a show
for an audience
that's excited to see it.
-That's it.
-Yeah.
-That's all
you have to worry about.
-Well, I'm very excited
that you're on the cusp of that
very soon.
-Thank you.
-And I can't wait for it.
And it's just so lovely
to have you back.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
-Thank you.
-Annaleigh Ashford, everybody.
"Sweeney Todd" is in previews
at Broadway's
Lunt-Fontanne Theatre and
officially opens on March 26th.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."